the sheer amount of [__] that we see in
process mentally daily like I don't
think humans are even supposed to be
doing that yeah like think if it's like
you know and little little Mary Jane
like this [__] didn't have Twitter and
all and just see all the [__] with all
these girls half naked by [__] 13
being over sexualized and she's like
well I need to change myself and I need
all like that [__] didn't exist well
that's I you know I wonder a lot of
times I think
you know and I've jerked off recently
I'm gonna be honest with everybody but I
think that a lot of times we've
exhausted our sexuality so I like you
know I feel like you're you're even
maybe even through a DNA strand you're
only supposed to see so much Cooter and
everything over time and ass or whatever
I actually agree with that oh so it's
crazy that now you're having children I
think that have no sex because you
[__] you you know Ronnie the daddy or
whatever spewed it all out dude that's
why I [__] Ernie is just sitting in
the yard
[__] licking rocks and scrolling on
Tick Tock because he can't even he don't
even have anything left in him you know
it's like it's weird like whenever we
created digital media it's like we
burned it out all out of us I think
there's a lot of men out there who are
gay not even because they want to be
it's because they all the straightness
got jerked out of them over time
wait what yeah
if somebody wants to be [__] gay
they're just gay oh well some people are
but some people some people their their
predecessors have just just busted so
many nuts that they or even them but
there's a difference wait no but it's
like then what you're talking about is
more so celibacy rather than a sexual
orientation I don't know man I think we
don't know the long-term effects of some
of this pornography think about it dude
like like when you're saying back in the
day you go to maybe the store and you
see a woman pick up a melon oh yeah jerk
off in the truck and you think about it
oh that was insane every time you
[__] see a an avocado salad you
[__] gotta hide in the in the in the
in the Outhouse when I was a kid I used
to [__] watch anime and I just be in
my head thinking about like this anime
[__] with big ass tits and I'm like 12
years old and oh yeah bro because I
didn't have anything I didn't have
[__] porn I have [__] internet you
know what I'm saying I was busting nuts
to [__] pencil
drawings damn dude it was a Vibe though
I remember one time I busted so many
nuts the first time I ever busted a nut
oh yeah take a second I busted like 14
nuts I was like 12 years old and I'm
shooting ghost loads daytime or night
time um night all night literally I it
was the first time because you know it's
like my dick would get hard this or that
I'm like 12 bro but like
you know that would get hard when my
dick would get hard a lot you like
Batman what yeah so like I was like I'm
on the Gravitron at the fair or whatever
yeah the [__] UFO literally I would I
I you know I just I'd never busted a
night and then you bust that first nut
and it like
opens your mind you're like oh my God so
I jerked off all night
and then my dick was like all fat oh it
hurts it hurt and I went to school next
day and it was like I was walking weird
and then I I came home and I was like
man I talked to my friend I was like yo
I think my dick's [__] up can you look
at it he's like what you only look at
your dick and I was like yeah man it's
all good dude that's exactly what I'm
talking about you do it so much you end
up in a gay instance what can I say what
can I say but no it was it was hilarious
he was like yeah he's just [__] up you
need to chill so I was like okay and
then I told you that yeah he was just
like yeah that's not normal man yeah you
know yeah I remember getting so much
ointment and I would pack it around my
weiner because it would like I just
exhausted its use so much and I would
get like all that Neosporin are you
being serious oh 100 and I would put it
all around it because it would hurt you
know I mean Louis CK was on here and we
talked about that about
imagine if you had a friend that was
your wiener and you just kept [__]
pet every time he was around you just
kept [__] shaking him around till he
spit up all over and then he did it and
then everybody's like let him rest let
him rest you're like nah [__] get him
back oh my God how many nuts have you
busted in a day oh not that many I'm
more of a I'm more of a long I'm more of
like uh like draw it out Edge
I wouldn't even call it edging I would
just call it very lazy kind of archaic
nuts you know I think chaic nuts I think
maybe four oh man I got you beat
[Laughter]
it bums me out if I do it a little bit
it bums me out you know what I'm over
porn
I'm so over it what's horrible they used
to have oh they said this actually seven
states pushed to require ID for watching
porn online Louisiana just did this and
I think this is one of the best things
that's ever been done for sure because
dude I really do think uh logic that
this this has ruined a lot of
relationships it's like it used to be a
woman was where
any fantasy you had was directed towards
your spouse
towards your wife
um and then now
those fantasies are all exalt you that
person can't even compete with the the
the the digitality of of all this
pornography yeah what does that article
say I'm sorry Zach
Gotta Love Zach I love Zach thanks bro
he's good man and I've never told him
that so I'm glad I'm actually no he's
great he is after Decades of can we zoom
in a little bit
after Decades of fretting over miners
potentially being Overexposed to
pornography online several states are
suddenly moving fast in 2023 to attempt
to keep kids off porn sites by passing
laws requiring age verification no but
that's real I mean have you ever seen
like those funny tick tocks or things
where it's like literally eighth grade
and the band's playing at lunch and then
they'll stop and then the kid does the
PornHub drum thing as like a joke and
then all the kids laugh because they
know it's it's [__] deep man because
like I remember the first time I was
exposed to pornography I was like five
years old no yeah but it was it was
print that's how old I am it was print
yeah same it was print magazine but I
just didn't understand I remember going
up to my my mother and once again she's
a huge I don't know [__] on her here but
I'm just being honest she's a [__]
hypocrite because you know I was like
what's sex
I was five years old and I asked her and
she was like
that's sex and I'm like what the [__] oh
she did that she did this she just went
like that and I was like oh [__] so then
I went to my homies I was like yo check
it out I'm having sex right now and I'm
like telling all my friends and [__]
they're like what the [__]
um but yeah I mean and that's not like
that bad like seeing seeing like a
little nudie magazine when you're grown
no you're growing up like but now it's
[__] deep man like I remember one of
the first times I like was on the
internet watching like 2006 2007. we're
like I didn't even know where to go and
I mean like Yahoo like just typing [__]
and like some chicks like going down on
this guy and then she like pukes all
over his dick and I'm like scarred and
I'm like oh my God like that is some
[__] people don't need to be like a
Golden Corral I know and now that's my
fetish
but it's like it's it's just a weird
thing but yeah it's over exposure man
well it's crazy but the the harm it does
to us I think that's the things we don't
know it's like that harm it used to be
you would take all those feelings and
you put them to every time you saw your
spouse you fantasize about him and if
you're open if you're open you're like
hey what's up you're trying to wear this
maid outfit and yeah you know pretend uh
you know XYZ like it's just to have
those fantasies you know and my wife
she's she's super open her [__] dad's
probably watching this right now so I'm
not going to get too deep into it but if
you know what I mean yeah but no she
she's my wife man she's she's incredible
you know what I mean she really
satisfies me and that's another thing
when I think like all through my 20s I
was just like jerking off watching porn
just because it was just kind of a thing
to do not a lot not crazy like I never
had an addiction nothing like that
um you know and I've known some some
dudes who have and have beaten that
which I think is great
um but I'm just like for what I kind of
I'm almost like saying it like saying it
all yeah and now I want to just like not
anymore
and just focus on my personal sexual
relationship with my wife not that I'm
not or haven't but just to eat even more
I think porn has been so
normalized in a way
um
which is not it's like as an adult like
to each their own you know what I mean
but I just think this [__] about making
sure that miners can't aren't really so
exposed to it I think it is important
porn has
just [__] with the youth thinking like
yeah [__] take this dick yeah like all
this and it's like that's really I mean
it's a time and place you know what I'm
saying it's definitely evening but you
know like your first time yeah you can't
be like that and then a girl thinks like
all this crazy and then here's the crazy
part you're not even connecting with the
other person at all now you're almost
performing
actions that you've seen so then it's
like the human connection it's totally
gone it's like we're almost it's become
weird because with porn you're almost
start to
and with everything digital you almost
start to impersonate what you've seen
yeah so now we've taken art in all forms
and some people consider porn art and
that's fine
we've taken art we've made art and now
we're watching the art we've made and
reenacting the we don't it's like we're
we're done yeah all I know is like my
first time having sex I was like [__]
Titanic wow really it was like I love
you oh my God
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one